that was the second time we played the
first time we was finna go to oakland to
play them it's speech week it's a
rivalry game everybody giving a speeches
man saying one of our coaches on the
broncos they think it's [ __ ] fashion
shows they're running out with change if
i was playing i snatched that [ __ ] so
i'm like hold on coach
got real goons in here
[Music]
so who we got in the pool hall today my
boyfriend to leave what's good baby i'm
all good how are you good man see you on
tv now yeah
you know what i'm saying how nice you're
in the breaking i'm all right let's
let's see what you can do man one take
drop something lee got the stripes in
too yeah you got to drop some
yeah take the easy one of course you
play defense too yeah exactly
what got you in the cornerback why'd you
play that position i'm born in cleveland
ohio but we was a cowboys fan you know
dion sanders that's kind of when i
started watching prime was on and that's
how i started playing cornerback bro i
always wanted to be a db over anything
else the demeanor of a cornerback what
does it take to be a great quarterback
in the league you got to have a lot of
confidence right because you go against
like the most confident guys on the
field in white house they like the most
confident guys so you got to have a lot
of confidence and you can't really care
to lose you just gotta won't smoke you
know what i'm saying let's talk about
your career in the nfl okay yeah
how was your experience like at the with
the bucks what was it like having that
training camp experience
facing the patriots i enjoyed every
moment of what was it my fourth year my
fifth year actually my last year you
know you had a training camp we kind of
started the joint practices that's kind
of when it started i wanted to impress
bill honestly i'm saying the whole time
i'm playing i keep on looking at bills
so man i'm strapping people up in
one-on-one honestly i had a great two
days worth of practice yeah i'm saying
i'm
bullying these special teams i don't
even practice in special scenes i'm
going going against later man i'm
throwing him right here oh probably yeah
so yeah yeah
so i want to go handling throw him out
of bounds we're talking all kind of [ __ ]
to him man anybody could do special team
[ __ ] i felt like i had a great practice
in uh those training camp battles in i
feel like that had a lot to do with how
i got there so what happened how did you
get to new england training camp we
didn't took some adderall we're hearing
all about the adderall let's take one
for this night practice like game like
situation next day we end up having a
test so bam
my suspension start so i had to train at
img that made me go to img academy you
know do my training there stay there i
had a room and everything finished my
workout sam in the hyperbaric chamber
little ass tube i'm saying sleep
my phone start going so i see a new
jersey number i ain't got this [ __ ]
saved
so i'm like hello
and then shiano he like keith i'm like
what's up coach
i just want to be the first one to tell
you
we're going to trade you to new england
so i'm like damn he like yeah man the
owners he kind of put it on them
next year so i wanted to make sure we
put you in a in a good position to
succeed i'm saying so that's how he
kicked it to me
yeah
all right all right i guess i can't be
mad at that right all right so then boom
my brother was beeping in right when he
talking to me so i'm like all right
coach my agent calling me i'm gonna call
you back todd what's up he like hey man
they trading it to new england i'm like
[ __ ] i heard
i already know [ __ ] so he's like man
well look i think it'd be a good thing
man we're gonna go here you'll be on the
stage the first game back you got a tv
game versus coach it's a late game 4 30
game you're already on tv just like
those patriots coast game back then too
patriots coach games man so i end up in
new england first game i get a pick
andrew luck off go to the crib and
before the game i started to get the
feel like damn this [ __ ] different
because the media is
times 10. the whole atmosphere is times
10 but after the game i got the
interception to the crib man it was just
like it was like a super bowl
environment but it wasn't [ __ ] but uh
you know i'm saying a pronoun game yeah
nine game or something like that right
so
right then i knew like this why bro was
so excited because he knows it's the
real stage so now i really get the
opportunity to show my skills and i'm
saying
get to the real real nfl yeah i'm saying
so how'd you land on the broncos i had
two nice little seasons with the
patriots boom it's contract time so now
i feel like i'm one of the hottest guys
out right now and at the time when new
england really wasn't paying people like
that where they are i mean not really
but you know bill bill is he going
general manager mode right he wake up in
the morning
it's bill belichick he's like keeb all
right what you gonna do i'm like bill
[ __ ] i can't do no more one of your
deals bill you give me a hard ass job
you give me a hard ass assignment you
know what i'm saying i need to get paid
like that right so free agency time my
agent called me he like man sit down i'm
like all right all right he called boom
the broncos man they want to give you
60. i'm like oh we're there
so you go from a team led by tom brady
to a team led by
peyton manning mm-hmm it was crazy man
it was super similar bruh it was like
what about
they almost like coaches it's almost
like they like gm coaches and players
they got so much say so with the coaches
with the teams it was a great experience
man just to go from one to the other man
and just see how both of them work and
see why both of them always in the
playoffs fc championship stuff like that
what do you remember from the superbowl
i remember falling on that stage
i definitely remember that so after the
game you win the super bowl
excited would you jump on the nfl
network set
yeah yeah yeah so you know it's bananas
after the game man then one of the media
people came
and was like prime wanna talk to you so
i'm like oh [ __ ] i remember probably
remember where they said it was over
there right so i uh i left the media
person hit it it was like a couple of
you know security gates how am i clear
the security guard jump over that one
huh jump over that one prom hop on the
stage
damn
at this point because you're wearing
cletuson with the the it was like you
know it's still the stage like steel and
uh i had cleats on so slip as soon as i
get on there bust my ass boom i won't
hurt or not so i popped right up man
prominent was like oh [ __ ] oh he good
it was just a good moment man i'm saying
it was a good moment up there with prime
irving guys who i looked up to them guys
him saying winning the super bowls and
stuff that's what made me want to play
football so that's why i was so excited
to go get on the stage with them boys
man so prom obviously influenced a lot
in terms of your style and the position
you want to play having seen him
immediately afterwards for you is that a
full circle moment for you man full
circle and then i say prime but i'm a
big michael irving fan too man yeah i'm
saying just cause i was a huge cowboys
fan so just seeing them boys i'm like
that was full circle like i'm actually
just one a chip i'm the best corner on
the team i'm saying i'm one of the best
corners in the league like [ __ ] i'm up
here with these boys let me get this
shot in i ain't got no shots right now
playing all this defense bro you ain't
even doing that
how do you describe dallas to other
people who ain't from here this city
different bro man dallas is [ __ ] man
look
dallas is a slow la that's what it is
it's a lot like la is just a little more
laid back a little slower but as far as
nightlife and day parties and
fun day you can man come on bro i'm
telling you
you can do anything you do like you can
do it right here in dallas straight up
bro for real
speaking of dallas you've had some
history with a couple people here yeah
including michael crabtree yeah i've
asked people around the city just trying
to understand it better understand where
this started from and no one really
knows they just ate some dallas [ __ ]
they started on some dallas [ __ ] just
because i was playing for tampa my dog
was playing for san fran i think and
then i don't know whatever happened in
the play a little scuffle in the play
and crab was just like
you from my [ __ ] city i better
not see you in the city so i'm like all
right all right fam all right so when i
see you you know just had the same
energy fam so you know i think maybe
that off season next off season whatever
i'm in north park mall so we're in the
norfolk i'm saying he's from the south
i'm from the north pacific you from you
from north dallas he's from oakland here
in the north i see him boom he actually
with a guy who i go to school with so i
know the guy you with right he ain't the
hardest guy you with yeah i'm saying i
see who you where i'm with wifey what's
up bruh and he was like man keith what's
up so i'm like all right all right i'm
just checking your energy family
exchange words whatever whatever no
smoke i'm saying
boom so now i'm on denver here on the
raiders we get on the field you know von
miller he kind of mutual friends between
both of us so we got into it again on
phil he talking i'm like but tell him
about when i see him at the mall then
you know led to another man then boom we
finna play the raiders i think next
season or whatever it's kind of like you
know led up to this point january i
think it's new year's right 2017. i
don't know i have no idea about the
dates math but that was the second time
we're playing the first time we're just
finna go to oakland to play them it's
speech week it's a rivalry game
everybody giving these speeches man one
of our coaches on the broncos they think
it's [ __ ] fashion shows they're
running out with change if i was playing
i snatched that [ __ ] so i'm like hold on
coach got real goons in here y'all
better yeah
that's a joke right you know i'm saying
i think i hurt my back or something in
practice that week so i didn't even go
to oakland to play them so now we finna
play them again in the same coach he
kind of what i'm saying we went out
there got our ass whooped they went
change and [ __ ] well we kind of got on
it again right yeah i got it in my head
like man i'm embarrassed
i'm gonna snatch that [ __ ] right
when the game start i'm locked in though
i ain't thinking about no chain i'm
thinking about winning this game i'm
saying we're gonna win this game
whatever and they throw him like a
little fade i strap it up ain't nothing
i pushed him on the ground so then i
kind of was over him so he kind of got
up boom with like a little shoulder
check to my chin and [ __ ] and after that
all i can see is the chain
i just could see the chain right there
trying to snatch it i thought i had it i
took like three steps i looked look back
it's kind of hanging on his neck right
here
kind of hanging so i'm like damn i ain't
even get it
i can't really hear what he was saying
i'm yelling [ __ ] he got not [ __ ] you
can't really hear what each other saying
i'm saying but you know i just wanted to
embarrass him the second game i don't
even remember we in oakland so boom he
come out he kind of boom shot chris in
the stomach boom chris harris on the
other side shot him in his stomach bam
so he stopped to play i'm saying injury
time out he like bro you shot me in the
stomach you watched the film you could
see him he sucked him in the stomach
long little 10 minute break or whatever
next play come out on my side the run
play he did the same thing so i'm
laughing like you just did it to chris
boom i feel i feel the little point boom
so i'm laughing how he just started
pushing me blocking me like i think he
gonna let me go i ain't really on that
[ __ ] this time i'm like [ __ ] over what
it's old he still was mad i guess he's
blocking me he's blocking me so while he
blocking me again all i seen was the
change
i'm being funny at this point
that's it again he keep blocking me
though finally fall down and then after
i failed i'm like it's up now i'm gonna
fight you
finally had it but then i dropped it
again
got into a little scuffle with him man
came around seeing him
tried to take off on him man it was a
whole little situation because he was
helping us at that point yeah yeah yeah
yeah open face yeah i snatched his
helmet off try to throw it at him man
bad decision man whole gang check a lot
of money a lot of money i lost a lot of
money i'm just like following you for
that because y'all jacob you're getting
fined by the game so yeah i mean divide
that by 17
and that's your number per game
so that [ __ ] up there actually probably
like half a million dollars they took a
whole check they tried to take two
luckily elway went to bat for me man you
have a call right you on pill they we
should spend your two games so you have
an appeal man elway went to bat for me
ended up getting dropped to one game i
think so
a lot of respect for elway man he was on
the phone going ham for me too with the
league office man so bad decisions a lot
of money though let me knock a few in
real quick
yeah man but i wouldn't even know that
the second time but you know i i did the
first time
he kind of did the second time so man
since then i seen him man one time we
was at the go-kart place i'm with the
kids it's me wifey i got my nephews we
like 11 d i got like nine little nephews
cousins with me crab walking with his
girl with like six of his little nephews
right so we ain't got no homies with us
let's walk in i stand up like bruh you
straight he said hell no i'm like
straight i started laughing every time
i'm shot like i'm right here he came
past he like hey bro come outside come
outside so i hopped up quick walk right
outside which was me and him and then
i'm saying we kind of man what's up what
are we on it's will you tell me we kind
of got to the bottom of we kind of
squashed him saying through it out the
window brother [ __ ] pointless bro what
we on i'm glad you said it bro cause i
feel like dallas can create that kind of
energy sometimes sometimes it can i'm
saying i'm glad i ran into him at the
go-kart spot kind of dead that [ __ ] man
i'm saying we're too old for that [ __ ]
how do you look at that from your fans
point now because it's important for you
for like people from dallas like to be
on that unity stuff especially yeah
it's a lot going on right now north and
south for ours right now and it don't
have to be like that it's a lot of money
to be made and they could be making a
lot of money together but it's easier
said than done for real precept man
y'all doing those kind of truths man it
can go a long way for people to
understand like you said a lot of money
be made out here bro real [ __ ]
[Music]
60 seconds let me ask you questions as
you shoot you ready i'm ready let's get
it let's do it three two one let's get
it
favorite statement of playing oh
favorite state in the play in atlanta
that's tom brady or peyton manning i
can't even answer that
nah you got a big one come on bro
biggest financial loss ever made better
risk of the ribs
this year's mvp tom brady hardest wide
receiver to cover calvin johnson super
bowl parties for pro bowl parties pro
bowl party
favorite qb to pickle
single bets are parlays barley talk
about favorite team you played for
bronco 10 seconds who are you listening
to before a game rihanna best corner bag
of all time
five seconds dirty is the phone you've
ever faced pierre garcon
super prediction you got bucks chiefs
running back running back in that lake
running back in l.a keith man appreciate
you coming by bro appreciate having man
already
[Music]